as our honor and distinct privilege to
have as our commencement speaker the
very distinguished dr. Larry P Arn dr.
arm became the 12th president of
Hillsdale College in two thousand he
received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD in
government at the claremont graduate
school he studied as well at the London
School of Economics and at war Chester
College Oxford University where he
served as director of research for the
late sir martin gilbert the official
biographer of winston churchill dr on is
the author of liberty and learning the
evolution of American education the
founders key the divine and natural
connection between the Declaration and
the Constitution and what we risk by
losing it and Churchill's trial Winston
Churchill and the salvation of free
government ladies and gentlemen dr.
Larry P Arn
thank you very much congratulations
Emily and Jessica understanding and on
those beautiful remarks and to all of
your seniors congratulate you on the
board I'm proud to be here turns out the
great mr. theory here whose son is
coming to hillsdale college next year I
was thinking I own that man now I can do
anything I want to with him as I do
surely on that boy but then it occurred
to me I'd forgotten about the exchange
that's happening because our youngest
son tony is going to teach Latin working
for mr. theory next year
we have exchanged hostages I'm an old
hand at commencement and so I know it's
important to recognize the most
important people in the room who turn
out to be the faculty members how many
of them are here would you stand up for
a second so we could see you
thank you
thank you for your work I'm going to
commiserate with you in just a minute
and the parents of students in the
school how would you stand up just a
minute
I'm going to commiserate with you too
and I know that there are a group of
friends of the college who've come here
tonight and I want to thank you for
being here and tell you that amidst all
the trouble in the world of college as
well and we're going to go ahead and
have college again next year for the
hundred and seventy fourth time i'm
going to introduce t Barney to you until
you just a little bit about how this
works all this charter school stuff and
then I'm going to say a few words to the
most important people this night the
seniors who by the way I spoke with for
a few minutes and they're polite smart
cheeky just what you'd want Steve barney
is a friend of mine in a trustee of the
college and some years ago he became the
second person to thump me on the chest
and tell me that I you Larry have to do
something about K through 12 education
and steve is a blubber baby he works up
tears about the fate and plight of the
young and I allowed that I had thought
of something and I told it to this other
person who was soon killed in a plane
crash and Steve said he was going to
make that happen and the something is
simple enough any good human Enterprise
is centered around the actual factual
thing it's supposed to accomplish in the
case of a school the purpose is
education education comes from a Latin
word these scholars will tell you that
means to lead fourth fourth is a
direction also it's a value term and so
we forget that today you just read any
bureaucrat any politician Republican or
Democrat and you won't find one in a
hundred you can tell you what education
is I'm giving a big talk in Washington
next week because somebody gave me a
prize and there's going to be a lot of
important people there so I'm going to
now it's the obvious fact that everyone
knows and nobody says which is the
people in the Department of Education
wouldn't know an education if it bit
them on the butt
so we have eight charter schools now and
for more opening in August I think
that's the right number by the way I did
have something to do with conceiving
this mess and the reason it isn't a mass
is because of Phil who might think so
very much for running all this and
making it work he does the work and I'm
just here to take a credit which is an
excellent position for me to be in we
don't take any money from these schools
because we don't take any money from the
government we can't really we spend so
much time trying not to be run by the
federal government that we don't have
any time left over trying not to be run
by the government in New Mexico which
would be about as miserable as being run
by the federal government so what we do
for these schools we raise the money to
do with Steve's very great help and a
lot of people's helped hundreds of
people now have given to help us do this
we've spent some millions of dollars on
it about a third of our faculty he'll
still mr. theory is about to find out is
a very challenging college it's hell I
urge you not to come and and one of the
reasons it's hell is because there's a
faculty member for every nine students
and they're very smart and they love to
teach and they have just fallen in love
with this project and so they spend part
of their time and we pay them for
training teachers and help them figure
out how to run charter schools and we
give them advice and we learn from them
and so we become also a clearinghouse
for advice and I want you all to know
that this is a privilege for us to do
it's an inspiring thing to do and it
owes so much to Steve Barney and you
should thank him
now for you seniors I think it's time to
ask the question why a classical
education and I want you to know that my
expertise is in torturing the young and
it's easy after you come to understand
them by the way if you do come to
understand them you will love them these
are super by the way and as i like to
say but if you just ask them point-blank
what any fundamental thing means they're
young they can't tell you it's hard
right i mean how many people in this
room could stand up right now and give a
good definition of the laws of nature
and of nature's God you've heard the
expression right it's in the Declaration
of Independence I think Bill Clinton it
was once identified that it's coming
from the Gettysburg Address but it
actually isn't easy to say what those
laws are or how would you you would know
what they are and education is another
such term and classical is such a term
by the way we apply the classical term
in education to a period of history in
Greece and Rome that doesn't cover the
entire history of those two places why
are they classical why is classical good
the leading experts by the way in this
room on why not to do classical
education are those people sitting right
there and their teachers and their
parents because it's terribly
troublesome to do I mean first of all
homework out to the zoo and you I don't
know what's wrong with you your warped
in some way or another because what kids
to do now do today did you know in the
Republic of France for two years now
homework has been outlawed on on the
argument that some kids when they go
home don't have people to help them with
their homework and so it's unequal for
parents to help students learn
right but that's very widespread in
America today which means that these
kids have missed parties and fun and
dances and TV and movies that all of
their peers have enjoyed what is wrong
with you people and young is the very
time when you can best enjoy those
things what were you thinking and then
Latin why Latin god help us I mean it's
a dead language even if by the way
there's getting to be almost no reason
to learn any other language because soon
it's already working it's just not
widespread yet Skype is going to let is
going to provide automatic translation
in real time between any two people in
the world whether they speak the same
language or not so why would you learn
another language indeed by the way you
could have a conversation with somebody
I imagine soon in Latin when neither of
you knew Len think of that does that
make sense no but think think of this by
the way it won't be long till will be
resurrecting Cicero and we won't need to
know his language to talk with them so
what I learned is hard to learn Len for
the parents it's hard because your kids
are under stress more than other kids
isn't that right don't they turn into
vampires at the end of the term they
look like these dark circles under their
eyes you should come to Hillsdale
College in September in October Hills de
and also in January in February
hillsdale college is like Disneyland
everybody is so happy but then in
December and in April it's like a zombie
movie because they're worn out it's hard
and it's hard on the faculty isn't it
because you know the grade it's a
distortion but the great idea today
about education is that students should
spend the time all day long doing
whatever happens to interest them and
see you know what it's a distortion
enough I'm going to talk about this for
a second later it's a distortion of this
fact whatever these people here know how
many other nine of them however many of
these nine know whatever they know they
don't know it because their teachers
knew it I've learned this myself
teaching there's some things there are
three things that I know as much about
as any living person I fancy that
they're important things and I've spent
40 years learning them and i start
teaching regularly 15 years ago and i
discovered i can't teach it to the
students unless they work and seek it
hard and all i can really do is bore
them especially if i make the mistake of
trying to tell them to easily and
quickly you always ask them first and
then when they give you the answer
especially if it's right it's important
to disagree with them you know because
they're young right and then another go
oh my god right and then they're really
thinking now see and and all you can do
if you don't do that is just give them
the conclusions you reached after all
that sweat and toil that's a truth and
if you think about that truth for a
minute implicit in that truth is the
very nature of human freedom every
achievement is because some free human
soul gives itself to that achievement
and sacrifices for that achievement and
today by the way we take that deep and
beautiful truth and we turn it into the
doctrine that they should be permitted
to do whatever they want I took our
eldest child all of our children but our
eldest child to other colleges for
interviews because some of them didn't
want to come to the College where I work
the eldest child by the way runs one of
these charter schools in austin texas
today's their last day and she's saying
she's awesome by the way and way better
looking than mr. theory on
and I'm sitting in it in a admissions
counselors office at a very
distinguished college where I got some
of my education and I said what are you
going to teach my daughter and the lady
replied whatever she wants to learn and
I said she would be coming here to get
an education and the lady said yes
indeed and I said implying that she does
not have one and now the lady got it
grew uncertain and I said in but she's
going to pick anyway huh so what a
teacher's do they help and they know to
start it passes down those are reasons
not to do it what reason is there to do
it I have just two points first of all
classical is not the fundamental word
that's an adjective the fundamental word
is a noun the word is class what is it
to be in a class well we have one here
the senior class how'd they get in it
because you know they took a bunch of
exams and they worked and they turned
into vampires at the end of the term and
there were others who started with them
and they're not sitting here now because
they didn't get through all that
sometimes not their fault sometimes it
was right these are receiving
certificate tonight that says that they
have the qualities of this class or to
use a synonym for the word qualities
they have the virtues of this class they
are members of the class because they
have the qualities that give the class
it's being you could say these kids are
clever by the way and one of them flirts
with nihilism down there on the end he
only he's only flirting by the way
he told me later it was just a joke I
think his mother teaches in the school
is that true no no maybe she should but
these are clever kids and like young
kids today they're good at cynicism and
so they could be thinking you know what
about the class pirate what about the
class thief what about the class
murderer what if i want to be a member
of that class well i have the qualities
of that class of those virtues that
those have and you know there's a
there's a pitfall there because lots of
us today when we think that anything has
any meaning whatsoever what we think of
is a great contest in the universe
between a mighty force of good and a
mighty force of evil and their and their
equal and their quarreling and you have
to decide you know in Star Wars right
the dark side of the force versus the
other side of the force but you know
what that argument won't work it won't
work because by the way if they really
were equal how would you know which one
to call good and which one to call evil
how would you know which one to call
light and which one to call dark there
has to be something beyond them to to
distinguish them some standard outside
and above them right and see if you take
someone's life or someone's property or
someone's honor unjustly that is to say
unduly and without their deserving it
you know what the word is for that that
means unjust in just which by the way is
only a term that has meaning if you know
what justice is evil is in fact only
good spoiled and you can't understand
evil without understanding the good that
is being ruined and we all know that all
the time and so what class do these
class
thinkers that we learn about and emulate
fit into what did they do that made them
classical they didn't call themselves
that by the way what they were to
themselves was revolutionary I'll tell
you what they did contained in an
explanation is my final point man named
Socrates the father of Western thought
philosophy Cicero says of him that he
called philosophy down from the heavens
and made it inquire into the things of
men before Socrates what philosophers
did Heraclitus stahley's parmenides what
they did were they were trying to find
out the component portions of the
universe that atoms and the void earth
fire wind and air long treatises about
that what makes up everything Socrates
their dialogues some of the most famous
and enduring things written in all of
human history that have the names of
some of those people that I just named
and what Socrates was did was he got
into a conversation with him and he
confronted them with the question that
faced those young people right now they
said he said and so you think that the
life of wandering about bad is the right
kind of life and you know you only get
one and you'll be dead before you know
it and the second that's just passed you
can never get it back their lives seem
long to them now but-- but we know that
their lives are fleeting and they know
that their youth is fleeting did you
catch the note of sadness in the
salutatorians remarks and the promise
that she would keep her friend till the
day she dies she already knows about her
longevity you see and so this life that
we have to live there's just one and the
question is how should we
of it what is the right way for a human
being to live and Socrates put the point
like that and he didn't say what is the
right way for an Athenian to live or a
Persian or a Spartan or in this time in
this place or in some future time or
some future place he said I would like
to know what is right for the class
human it is a very radical question it
goes along exactly by the way do you
know what Western civilization is do you
know what we mean by that expression
because by the way I personally have a
treasured and offensive letter from the
Michigan Department of Education another
place by the way where you can surely
find none and they said that there was a
problem with our curriculum in education
because we say that we study Western
civilization whereas global and
multicultural perspectives are to
permeate the curriculum and so I had
traipsed up to lansing michigan I've
been there twice in my life and hope
never third and I said you know I just
thought I'd mention to you that Western
civilization is the confluence of two
strains of thinking and one of them
comes from Jerusalem where the idea was
born that there was one God for every
man not not this city not this race not
these people every human being one God
the being of perfection in whose image
all of us are made it's revolutionary it
changes the religions of the ancient
world decisively right but the same
thing by the way that happened in faith
in Jerusalem happened in thought in
Athens
because Socrates's question was what is
that good and what is the true and what
is the beautiful because we need to know
those things so that we can live well
and the tension by the way Chrissy I
didn't come here to proselytize anybody
for religion I want you to understand
the grandness of the assertion it's
awesome and the tension is knowing by
faith and knowing by reason are
different ways of knowing and they may
come out to the same place but that's an
argument and you see those two
universals coming from those two
different cities they give definition to
the west and they're both Universal not
parochial the opposite of that I told
that to those people in Lansing and they
look puzzled what does this mean for you
the most important thing in my opinion
for young people to know is that things
are real you can trust your senses
they've all you got Aristotle writes
there's nothing in the soul does not get
in the earth by except by way of the
senses and as Nathan and I were arguing
this evening if you if you discard the
evidence of your senses you're left with
nothing which means that literally you
disappear and why would you want to do
that foolish thing anyway it means that
you would doubt a mother's love you know
the family is collapsing all over the
world these families represented here
that have produced that we're going to
be manufacturing children soon enough
because the technology exists and then
we can design them the way we want
predicted in 1931 by both Winston
Churchill and Aldous Huxley but if you
think that things are real then
questions become urgent and you get to
find out how ambitious you are because
you may be ambitious in
some low way ambitious to succeed
ambitious to be comfortable ambitious to
have money ambitious to be influential
or powerful but I want to tell you an
argument is my last point that you will
find in one of the two greatest of the
classical works in my opinion you know
in Plato's Republic Plato is writing a
dialogue about his teacher Socrates and
one of the most important characters in
a republic the greatest of the dialogues
is Glaucon who is Plato's brother and
they meet in the beginning and they talk
first with an old man and Ken Phyllis
and that goes a certain way and then the
first real argument comes very important
argument because there's a man named
Thor Simic asst and their cinakisz is a
softest many of the Platonic dialogues
have the names of sophists in the title
and through some aquellas is a famous
softest and here's what's office do they
teach young ambitious people how to be
powerful in exchange for money because
you know the decline of Greece and the
decline of Rome was connected to the
phenomenon that people just wanted
strength comfort pleasure sway money
look about the world today right and so
through Semak asst and Socrates our
competitors for the souls of the young
and influential like these because think
what they've done see it's unusual not
every kid in this day and age when there
are so many easy options by the way
Jessica enjoyed one of those options for
a while and then she stands up here and
talks about how proud she has to have
done this craziness does that tell you
something about her soul or Mason you
know who stands there and makes
nihilistic arguments to me because he
knows they're the most controversial
kind to make and it's his commencement
night he might as well make a stink
does that tell you something about his
soul is those souls that's what's
interesting for the future that's what
matters and Socrates says to the sim
because he says okay I give you so much
because his argument was justice is
whatever the stronger person wants
whoever's got strength he gets to say
what it is and I and the Socrates said
good I'll give you that now let's
appoint you the strongest man tell me
what your interest is tell me what is
good for you do you see how the question
immediately turns into the fundamental
question the question of the class or
the question of the good imagine
yourself strong and powerful in Sutton
Plato's Republic there's the story of
the ring of guy geez you put this rings
like in The Lord of the Rings you put
this ring on and turn it and you can
disappear and that means you can have
anything you want what do you do with
that power today in the world we are
gathering incredible power over
ourselves and over nature what should we
do with that power in an age where it is
thought that strength and success are
the only requirement there someone
because could not answer that question
because it cannot be answered because
strength and power the more you have of
it the more it raises the question what
are you to do with it what is the good
is more sharply presented to those who
exercise influence than those who don't
and so the word in greek is they rhian
thorson MCUs rose up like a wild beast
and shouted at socrates and left and
then this is my point my last point it's
my point for you Plato's brup brother
then rose up and said okay Glaucon said
to socrates and he gives him a command
see he says okay
then Socrates and by the way i will tell
you there's because i read this this
passage when I was a junior in college
that I am NOT a lawyer today I decided
to get an education instead show me
Socrates he said this ambitious young
man wanting ambitious in the biggest
possible way you see show me then that
justice is good and right even if by
practicing it you will win nothing but
punishment whereas if you would pick
injustice you could have your rewards
show me that justice is good for its own
sake now Plato's Republic is one of the
greatest books ever written and the end
you know it's 2,500 years later and we
still read it and the whole action of
Plato's Republic all of the rest of the
Republic proceeds from that command from
that ambitious young man and so my point
is simple the reason to have a classical
education is to nourish your soul to
elevate your ambitions and to live
virtuously and therefore happily
congratulations